Once simple way to think of transparency is that you want to see a bit of both
objects. So, say, we have these two objects on the screen and, so, opaque sphere
and this red filter on top of it. This is a blow up of the pixels and this shows
the sphere itself being rendered. So, if we want to add this red filter, what we
could do is fill-in every other pixel with red to make it look semi-transparent.
The idea here is that pixels are tiny. So ,the eye will blend the two colors
together to get a magenta when the objects overlap like this. This is a very
limited form of transparency, however. It only supports two objects and only a
50/50 mix looks good. This algorithm is called Screen-Door Transparency because
you're treating the pixels as like they're a screen door, and you're filling in
every other pixel with a semi-transparent object.